happy monday reject nation we're gonna
watch today
from ryan george how they wrote classic
christmas songs perfect way to get
ourselves into the holiday
spirit for what is sure to be not a
traditional type of christmas year let's
do this
this video is sponsored by nordpass more
about that at the end of the sketch
okay so we have but the fire is so
delightful and since we've no place to
go
uh i will allow it to snow proceed with
the snowing now
we're not quite there but definitely
something about permission what about
let it snow let it snow there it is
great suggestion
thank you okay so let's take a break
from that song for a minute let's go
back to that winter wonderland song we
were working on sure so what's some
what's some relatable stuff you do in
the winter
you listen to sleigh bells sleigh bells
ring are you listening love it you uh
you build a snowman
you build a snowman you do that that's
good that's good maybe in a meadow in
the
meadow we can build a snowman i love
that absolutely yeah we are on a roll
guys
yeah yeah yeah then you pretend he's
parson brown
what what is that the snowman right
you pretend he's parson brown who is
that yeah
just parson brown parson it's like is
this someone you know personally yeah
this is supposed to be relatable we
can't include lyrics about some guy you
know
no parsing person it's
priest in the church of england what
yeah this guy's like an
anglican a protestant minister guy
doesn't exist though he's made up so you
pretend like the snowman is a
non-existent
minister you pretend like the snowman's
a non-existent minister that's right
nobody's ever done that with a snowman
okay
uh do we have any other ideas on the
table maybe something more relatable
maybe something about decorating the
snow then the priest starts asking you
and your girlfriend some questions
he starts asking about your loved one
how serious is it stuff like that
this isn't the thing he says are you
married you say no
man you tell this guy no and this is
something that all couples do with stuff
[Laughter]
yeah and then they go home or something
imaginary religious leaders rarely come
into play if ever
i'm just trying to make this song
relatable to everybody it's not i feel
like this is the opposite of that and
after you tell the priest you're not
married you tell him he can do the job
when he's in town that'll be the next
lyrics so you're pretending the snowman
is a priest named parson brown who's not
even
physically there yeah what do you mean
when he's in town you said you're
pretending the snowman is
parson brown later in the song we can
pretend the snowman's a clown a clown
from the circus we can pretend he's a
circus clown
what circus that has nothing to do with
christmas listen fellas we can always
run these ideas by my father
see what he thinks okay okay okay you're
lucky your dad's the ceo of this vague
company that writes all christmas music
for some reason yeah what is our
business mom
i think people are gonna like it yeah
well we'll see about that okay let's
shift our focus to a different song
let's try to do something relatable this
time okay okay so how about a song where
a woman
really wants to leave a man's house but
he's not letting her yeah that sounds
great to me
i see nothing wrong with that oh no
oh it's me i'm not uh
don't give your password away like that
that's not safe yeah what the hey who
are you i'm the freaking out of the nord
astronaut
okay the workplace checks out it's
important to keep your password safe
online nor pass is powered by nordvpn
cyber security professionals and it lets
you not only save all your passwords in
one secured password
but also generate new ones that are even
more secure well that's good to know
because i've had my passwords and
identity stolen five times this week yes
so sounds like you should use nordpass
probably
it's real simple to use and it protects
your sensitive information in fact wired
magazine called it one of the best
password managers to secure your digital
life hello would anyone like my credit
card
information and passwords do not give
out that information
uh okay and hey you can get 70 off nor
passes two year plan and a month
70 percent off oh my god that's a good
deal
that's less than the price of a cup of
coffee depending on where you buy your
coffee we should react to brand deals
oh my god definitely stop giving out
your personal information
good call north astronaut thank you
[Music]
oh that was great got there that's
fantastic wow
very very true i don't really listen to
that many christmas songs there's one
christmas song i love
that i listen to quite a bit and i kind
of listen to it all year round
uh all year long that is
sia's she had a whole christmas album
and it was sia's a ho ho ho song
i love that tune that's my favorite but
i completely agree
with the satirical assessment here a lot
of the time
they don't even make any sense yeah but
they're traditional and we sing along
and they rhyme so might as well just
roll with it
i had so many flashbacks during this bit
to like multiple family gatherings in
which the
lyrics specifically got discussed and
yes that i i never
thought directly about it but that is
one of the weirdly specific
christmas songs that we say and i wonder
yeah how just who
and how i mean i'm sure you can look up
the songwriters and i don't imagine it
was quite as
like commercial boardroom as this but it
does make me wonder like you know at the
time someone's sitting there just going
i guess you know i'm just gonna throw
some random stuff
in for my own life and yeah if this song
takes off then you know everyone's just
gonna keep parson
brown's memory live along with our
christmas clown
i mean i think christmas songs and
christmas movies are some of the most
commercial
ceo driven commercialism properties
out there if you're a successful
musician get yourself a christmas song
get yourself a christmas album yeah
because it becomes tradition
if even what like i i see his album is a
pretty big album and i
listen to ho ho ho all year long the
royalties
all i want for christmas i'm pretty sure
that's all mariah carey lives off of
this
it is the most commercialized thing you
can do and it's also the best time of
the year
that's the funny thing about it is even
i buy into it i buy into it all i don't
even go
like i don't scoff at it you're not a
screwdriver
yeah yeah this is working on me
you corporations rock you it works
i fall for it every time i'm a sucker
for it i'm gonna watch christmas
chronicles 2 on netflix this year
so yeah this was uh some pretty funny
stuff and i gotta say too ryan george's
ads are some of the absolute best
they're creative
they're really funny they're the kind of
ads that i want to sit through and he
i love that they let him do it however
the hell he wants to do it
which sometimes when we got brand deals
they were as loose with us as i'd like
them to be yeah
there's a lot of times we'll have like
wacky ideas and like no no no you can't
do that no you just gotta hit the bullet
points mother effort i'm like damn why
is ryan george gonna get away with
though what the hell
man come on george give us some of that
sweet sweet freedom give us the juice
that you got flowing in your brain and
the way you connect the networking you
do
i know you kind of know my brother son
of a [ __ ]
some [ __ ] it's because he gets hot
girls on to react to his videos with him
i'm not hot enough for you ryan george
is that only that okay i feel so i'll
work harder at it it's okay every once
in a while he likes a tweet of mine and
it makes me feel better about myself and
my well-being
anyway guys how they wrote classic
christmas songs what do you have planned
for the holidays this year what's your
favorite christmas song leave it down in
the comments
below did you watch fat man this year
yet subscribe to the real reject
subscriber ryan george click that
notification bell
we interrupt this broadcast because we
have a shout out to do for all the
patrons who are pledged
to our deleted takes and behind the
scenes tear they get a special
name call out so let's swing of action
kick us off john
lauren american horse the jedi bro
cj thomas peter pacheco russell beatty
gpk
joanna st louis matthew mensing
gregory bullock gilberto stephen mendoza
joshua ruiz body rot
rogue cree sam castle
sj99 sj94
runar k justin martin kayla waters
kenny waters rosie beatty darth yoda
order slick 26
ruby phillip j
smith jr jennifer
smith davidson
melanie leblanc natalie doran
irwin roger marcus verdeman
chase gardner eva drazdikova kim
mcknight
l zach right
kayla madrid oscar
matt beer sean island
andrew barber matt mac mac place
thank you guys so much for being pledged
to our patreon page your support means a
hell
of a lot keep looking out for all those
posts that we do especially our patron
lens you're the only guys get access to
it
much love peeps